hey everybody i'm off the grid for  august but the biden administration  still sucks  fine question we're always looking at  here in midterm election years the  president's job approval rating and you  see joe biden in our new poll 42  approved 55 disapprove it's been a few  months since the last nbc poll back in  may and the change since then really no  change biden's approval rating exactly  the same in our poll toward the end of  the summer as it was as the summer was  beginning and the key to this of course  obviously there usually historically has  been a pretty strong link between a  president's job approval rating and how  his party does during midterm elections  the only two times in modern history  that a white house party has actually  picked up seats in midterm elections was  bill clinton in 98 it was george w bush  in 92 their approval ratings were both  well above 60  bidens you see sitting in that zone  where presidents and their parties  typically have lost seats